news i know it can be tough to track all
of it
all the new vaccines new variants
so much that it is this moment that i
hope to be able to share with you the
latest that i know
and figure out what it means for all of
us where we live
where we work what the future looks like
as we take stock
of where we are today so i want to spend
time tonight trying to help make sense
of the news
and providing a snapshot of where we are
in our battle to end
this pandemic so let's start with the
good news
los angeles hospitalizations and
infections
both appear to be dramatically on the
decline
new coronavirus infections in la county
have dropped 20 percent over
last week when they were dramatically
down from the week before
and hospitalizations which is the key
metric that we use to gauge
the severity of the pandemic what's
coming next have dropped 13 percent
in the last week that tells us that your
commitment
to keeping your distance and washing
your hands to wearing your masks
and just using common sense are paying
off
thank you at the same time we're
vaccinating more people
more quickly and as of today the city of
los angeles has administered 206
644 vaccine doses at our five city
vaccination sites
together with the county hundreds of
thousands of people are getting
vaccinated
and we're averaging 11 310 daily
vaccinations at those five city sites
over the last week and i'm excited to
say we're finally scaling up
to our capacity dodger stadium from
vaccinating just 2540 people the first
day
to nearly 7 000 vaccine doses yesterday
and today
we have over 11 500 appointments
and as i started this 7 545 people have
already gone through
dodger stadium today there's one figure
that helps illustrate
how efficiently we're getting shots into
arms at those la city sites
as of yesterday we had put into the arms
of angelino's 97
of all the vaccines that the city had
received
that's one of the highest if not the
highest percentage in the nation
and l.a county has now vaccinated a
higher percentage of its population
than both the second and third most
populous counties in the united states
and globally we have now vaccinated more
people collectively
than have been diagnosed with covid
that's good news
that's a proud day for us all and today
with efforts
sorry today our efforts received an
additional boost with the biden
administration and governor newsom
announcing
that a federal state vaccination center
in the city of los angeles
would open up on the campus of cal state
la
i was very heartened to hear that news
it's slated to open
on february 16th and to open up on an
east side campus surrounded by
communities that have been among the
hardest hit
communities like boyle heights where my
family first came to this
city and grew up it means that the biden
administration the newsome
administration
are prioritizing those communities of
color that have been hardest hit by this
pandemic
this is good news and we stand ready to
share all of the lessons and the
capacity we've been building
with the work we've done at our
vaccination centers
we've heard a lot of dizzying talk
lately about efficacy rates and
how some vaccines might perform better
than others
but for those of us who aren't medical
professionals or researchers
it's important to know there are three
critical things to know
about our vaccines we want our vaccines
to prevent us from getting seriously
sick
we want our vaccines to prevent us from
becoming hospitalized
and we want vaccines that will keep us
from dying
and all of the authorized vaccines as
well as those
several that are still in trials meet
all three of those goals
let me be clear about that for the
public they reduce
the incidence of this disease the
hospitalizations
and deaths that is what this
whole year has been about saving lives
reducing hospitalizations
and having fewer cases the more vaccines
get distributed here in la and across
the u.s
simply put the fewer people will get
this disease be hospitalized by it
and die from it the fewer cases in our
communities
the more shots that go into arms every
single day and
the more evidence out there that these
vaccines
work all of this is good news
at the same time we're also monitoring
some emerging challenges
ones that are coming at us very fast
including the fact that the coronavirus
this novel coronavirus
known as kovitzars2 is itself mutating
the pneukovic strains appear to be
oftentimes much more transmissible
and may be somewhat more resistant to
some of our current vaccines
though there is no evidence at this
point that they increase
deaths among people who have been
vaccinated so they're not necessarily
stronger in the intensity
they just spread more easily and while
vaccines save lives and reduce
hospitalizations
new mutations remind us to keep up our
defenses
to continue the good things that you're
doing to protect yourself
and your family and your loved ones in
fact the head of the cdc dr rochelle
walensky said last week
she expects one of these variants to
become more dominant in the united
states by late
march or early april and many believe
that our surge in december and january
came from a more virulent variant that
came
through here these variants can undo our
progress
like that so our challenge as a city our
challenge as a nation
is clear don't let your guard down
we have to work together to buy time to
vaccinate more people
by slowing the spread of these variants
as vaccinations bring that protection
to more and more of our population
that's a big goal and our successes will
help determine how quickly we put this
pandemic
in the rear view mirror whether our
economy jumps back
more quickly than other places whether
people come here as tourists as
investors
whether jobs and hours are restored
businesses are back on their feet
but i know that achieving this ambitious
goal is absolutely within our power and
your power
if we double down on the tools we
already have hold off on getting
together with people outside of your
household
if you're going to watch the super bowl
this weekend do it safely
host a virtual watch party or talk about
the groom
the game over a group chat and as we
gear up to host the next super bowl
which will be right here in the south
land in the great city of inglewood
i promise you it will be worth the wait
that's how we ensure an extra measure of
protection against these new more
transmissible
strains and finally when your time comes
get
the vaccine i've been disturbed to see
across the nation that too many
vaccines are missing some of our most
vulnerable communities
this is unfair and it's bad public
health
here in los angeles we're taking action
to make sure that our most vulnerable
have access to these life-saving
vaccines so tonight
i'm proud to share with you a new
program to bring mobile vaccination
clinics to communities that have
suffered the
highest rate of disease and death from
covert 19.
together with our city council who held
hearings on seeing how difficult it is
the barriers to health to transportation
lower income communities and communities
of color often not having the access to
vaccines
just as we did with testing when we said
remember we're not waiting always for
you to come to us
we're coming to you we're now doing the
same thing with vaccines
we started yesterday in south los
angeles in partnership in council
district 8 with council member marquis
harris dawson
the noble the mobile clinic program
began delivering vaccines directly to
the community
to those seniors who need to get this
vaccine
but can't necessarily walk to or drive
to a vaccination center
we're working with the trusted
community-based organizations that our
department of aging
our city council offices and our
residents know and respect
and on the first day of this effort we
met our goal and we'll keep delivering
vaccines before
returning again in four weeks to provide
these community members with their
second doses
and next week in addition to serving
angelinos in council district 8
we'll bring an additional mobile clinic
to council district 9 council member
kern price's district
with the goal of scaling this program up
as quickly as possible
and i was also heartened to hear in the
governor and
the biden administration's announcement
that together with opening up the new
site
at cal state la they'll also be looking
at this model of
mobile teams that can go out there and
get the job done
this builds on what we did from the
beginning of this remember when i said
we were going directly with our surge
teams into our skilled nursing
facilities
and that we had been able to vaccinate
every single one of those vulnerable
seniors
who were disproportionately part of the
deaths that we saw at the beginning of
this pandemic
when between 35 and 50 of deaths were
those seniors in skilled nursing
facilities
we're going to continue doing the same
thing bringing the lens of equity
not just on this black history month not
just
in this very diverse city but because
this is good public health
to make sure those denser areas where
generations are living together
or where seniors are isolated and
vulnerable that we get the job done
nothing is more important no task more
urgent than making sure that
all angelinos have access to the vaccine
once they are eligible
and distributing it to those most in
need
if you're eligible there are three ways
to book an appointment
first through your doctor or health care
provider
second through visiting
vaccinatecounty.com
which now lists 300 vaccination sites
across la county including dodger
stadium and the five city run sites
or through the county department of
public health's call center
in other words you don't have to have a
computer to make an appointment
you just need to call if you're one of
our seniors and you need phone support
give us a call at 833-540-0473
led by the county with supplemental
staff from the city of los angeles we're
there to
answer your questions and to book you an
appointment if you're eligible
and all of these roads lead to that same
destination
an appointment to get vaccinated and
remember if you've gotten your
first dose at a city or county site you
don't have to do anything
your second dose appointment will be
scheduled automatically
you'll receive a text message or an
email a few days beforehand
if you called us we'll call you and all
you have to do is show up
if you have any questions about your
second dose including for anybody who
might not have received an email
with their second appointment you can
find further information at
coronavirus.lacity.org
second dose i can't emphasize
how important it is to stick with
trusted sources of information
when it comes to your medical health
when it comes to getting these doses of
this vaccine
stay vigilant against vaccine fraud
which unfortunately is happening across
our country
and even here in los angeles look out
for red flags that
indicate you might being scammed such as
messages suggesting that vaccination is
required by law
or asking you for money for vaccination
ads from unofficial sources on social
media
and offers to jump the line by paying a
fee
don't fall for these tricks and don't
respond to this kind
of outreach we need to all keep our
guard up against those bad actors
that would exploit this moment and your
vulnerability
the best way to protect yourself is to
stay up to date with vaccination news
and information
and you can sign up for a regular la
county newsletter and get alerts
about eligibility at vaccinatecounty.com
and i invite you to sign up for direct
updates from the city of los
angeles by going to
coronavirus.lacity.org
slash vax facts that's v-a-x-f-a-c-t-s
and getting our regular vax fax email
newsletter
not an easy word to say but an important
email to get
as we race to get our city vaccinated we
haven't stopped supporting those
angelinos
who are still in great need in the midst
of the economic
suffering that's part of this pandemic
partnering with the county we've
delivered grants to over 7
300 small businesses just to keep them
alive
to be able to pay their employees and to
make sure that they are there
when this pandemic is over and we've
distributed critical micro loans to a
further
800 businesses in need with the mayor's
fund of los angeles we launched the
serve initiative to get a one-time
eight hundred dollar stipend to over ten
thousand restaurant workers to help pay
their bills
when outdoor dining was suspended by the
county and to bridge that
until this point when it's back open and
we're providing one-on-one employment
support
to people in every neighborhood so if
you've lost your job or lost your hours
come to one of our 16 workforce centers
or our three portal offices
and and those same places we've helped
over 250 businesses
on the way to 2000 businesses to
optimize their digital presence
so that you can keep up with the trend
and keep up with the times
of contactless business of new web pages
and technology
so that you can get something that not
only helps you get through this pandemic
but thrive after it as well right now if
your business though there's a very
important piece of information you need
to know about
tonight applications are open again for
the california
small business covert 19 relief grant
program
so mouthful but this cal grant program
simply put is cash for your business
you can be a small business a non-profit
if you're feeling the pain of this
pandemic you can apply for a relief
grant
between five thousand and twenty five
thousand dollars
through the state of california go to
ca relief grant com
that's ca relief grant.com
by the end of the day on monday february
8th to apply
you see at every juncture in this crisis
we've tried to
raise the funds build the partnerships
think outside the box not ask permission
but just
rush in to do whatever we can to help
you whether it's grants or tests
vaccines this is a moment for us to join
hands together
and to not worry about jurisdiction or
territoriality but to
actually embrace the idea that we share
this
city together but we've come up against
the same truth time and time again
no matter how much creativity we bring
locally
we can't do this job alone we need the
federal government
our federal government where we pay our
taxes
to step up and help so at this critical
moment for our city across our county
and region
across america let me speak up directly
to our leaders in congress
thank you for the legislation you are
considering and no we can't wait another
minute for relief too many of our
families are hungry
tonight too many of our kids are in free
fall
at home right now too many of our people
are dying
and we're running out of time but you
can make a difference
any plan that doesn't include relief to
state and local government
should be dismissed out of hand and i
know there are some in congress who
suggested
that we could get on without that well
just as we funded
schools and just as we funded transit
agencies at the end of the year
but local and state governments were cut
out let's end the partisan games
and let's pass president biden's
american rescue plan
now this is how we will speed up
vaccinations
this is how we will accelerate help for
working americans
barely getting by who yes need fourteen
hundred dollars more
to pay their rent and to feed their
families
folks who need child care support and
tax credits school districts that need
more money to be able to get
open and of course city governments who
are fronting so much of the cost of this
pandemic
and need to be able to keep our
employees employed
and this economy going long before
covert when i talked about the
homelessness crisis too
i always said we needed a fema level
response
to a crisis that predates the pandemic
is involved in the pandemic and will
postdate this pandemic
and i was pleased that finally in the
midst of this pandemic we saw the
opening
of that door with fema offering to help
us get our unhoused neighbors
off the streets an unprecedented number
over 8 000 between the city and county
on top of the 24 000 plus we do in any
given year
of folks who are unhoused have come
indoors to shelters to housing
to transitional uh housing options and
permanent apartments
but reimbursing us just 75 percent
meant that we were carrying 25 percent
of that cost well last week
the federal government made a badly
needed change
they finally said that they would pay
for 100 of hotel rooms that are used
for unhoused angelinos to have a safe
place to be
especially when we've seen the rain in
the last month
so i've instructed my team and the city
council has instructed our city
government together
to with lasso bring hundreds more
angelinos indoors
by using those empty hotel and motel
rooms across the southland
and to find folks who are the most
vulnerable and put them in shelter
now this program has already brought two
thousand people
indoors in the city and four thousand
county wide project
room key it's called and together with
state funds it has been a success in
fact
i spoke with the administration last
week about how it's a model
of how they are thinking through how to
scale things up nationally
and why they went to 100 reimbursement
in other words california and los
angeles are leading
again coming up with solutions but also
demanding that they scale up
and this transformative change from fema
will allow our
most vulnerable to have safe shelter
hundreds more people that are on the
streets tonight
this month to become indoors especially
along skid row
we can see the light los angeles
i can feel it every day a little bit
more
every week a little bit brighter but
we've still got our work
cut out we still need more vaccines we
still have to keep our distance
we still have to face the moment that
we're living through
and so many families hanging on to their
loved ones
the trauma that our health care workers
see and witness and carry
with them every single day the essential
workers whether they're driving a bus
whether they're unloading the cargo
whether they're stocking the shelves
or whether they're cleaning the floors
who have never not
answered the call of this moment we owe
it to them
we know it to ourselves and to this city
to keep up that fight
and to do everything we can to take care
of each other
by remaining vigilant against this virus
buying time to slow the spread saying
yes when it's our time to get a vaccine
and to make sure that we stay healthy
stay safe
and stay at home right now whenever we
can
sending you all strength and love this
week
and always and with that happy to answer
questions thank you
first question please our first question
come from the line of claudia
prosciutto with knx news radio please go
ahead
hi claudia hi i have a couple of
questions
um so i'm sure you've had a chance to
read uh judge carter's latest order he
makes it clear that he is not faced with
the city's response to the homelessness
crisis
saying that the paralysis and the city
appears to be complete
and seems to lay the responsibility for
dealing with this emergency at your feet
so i'd like to get your response and
find out whether you're planning to
appear at tomorrow's hearing on skid row
and it does sound like the court is
threatening to take this over
and i'm wondering what you think about
that sure the second question
is you know teachers unions would like
their members vaccinated before schools
reopen the governor
cbc director and others insist it is
safe to reopen
before all teachers are vaccinated what
do you think l.a unified should do
thank you i'll start with valley unified
absolutely i think our highest priority
has to be our children
we've got card rooms open uh you know in
the past and school's not
let's get our priorities straight and
don't get me wrong
jobs are important too but our children
have been suffering and our children
that already suffer the most
are suffering the most on top of it
those who don't have connection to a
good
internet uh so don't have a connect
sorry don't have access to a good
internet
connection those who might not have the
technology they need they are
literally losing a year of their
education and in many ways
maybe sending them on a pathway where
they will never be able to recover
so i hope all of us all stakeholders our
districts
our federal and state governments our
local governments our
teachers our school employees are all
unified around let's get schools
open as quickly as we can and safely as
we can
now what does that mean i believe that
we should be absolutely putting teachers
and school workers
at the front of the line that they are
one of the most critical along with our
transportation workers
and our food workers who we should be
making sure has
access next if there are more vaccines
the state and federal government should
be prioritizing those for those schools
to get them open
second we have to accept there is no
perfect scenario
in which there's a vaccine that's a
hundred percent effective
and we're not just telling a school
district
or teachers or others what to do with no
experience the city of los angeles
thanks to the leadership of
council president martinez and others
we've been working to keep open
our rec centers with school-like
programming eight hours a day
with students this entire pandemic long
and my reckon park workers who i want to
thank
who have been that lifeline are acting
as that child
care in some cases educators and their
lives are just as important as anybody
else's
so i believe we can meet this moment the
challenge i have
is whether it's our teachers whether
it's our districts
tell us that standard be specific demand
from the federal government the
resources and the state you need to get
there
enlist whatever partners you need
including us we stand by ready to assist
and then let's get that job done instead
of saying
still didn't reach it still didn't reach
it and changing the bar each time
we have to take care of our kids second
in terms of judge carter i had a great
uh
meeting with judge carter yesterday uh
face to face when i did see that order
i am unable to come tomorrow and let him
know that but i said let's just sit down
the two of us
um i love judge carter um i think he's
fond of me i'll let him say it he said
it many times
and i'm very proud of the progress that
we have made
not only to meet the 6 700 additional
units and housing solutions we said but
to surpass that already
where we have over 8 000 identified over
half of them done
just a few months into the 18 months we
have to do that
this is immensely hard work but when you
look at there isn't hardly a week goes
by with not one or two either
groundbreakings or openings
of new permanent housing of new shelters
that are opening
of tiny home villages like the one that
i went to and council remember krokoyans
district and
cd2 where there was a previous
encampment there's now wonderful tiny
homes
right along close to the intersection of
where the red line
and the orange line meet um there is
distinct progress and like the judge i
share
that same sense of urgency we have to
keep
adding that which is why i talked about
the urgency of moving forward with
project room key the 100 reimbursement
from fema etc
none of us can be satisfied and in terms
of responsibility
it's not news to you or to anyone else
even though i'm really one of many
actors
three or four years ago i said i take
full responsibility for the response and
i hope that we all do
your last point was they're threatening
to take over the
the court doesn't have the jurisdiction
to do that at this point in fact the
case hasn't even begun
this is about the negotiations we can
have had a wonderful talk with the judge
and i hope that
the city will be able to come to a
global settlement with
the plaintiffs that are uh bringing this
lawsuit because i think we share the
same things get more people off the
streets even more quickly
there's no city in america doing more
but i share the same perspective as
angelino as most angelinos then why do
we still have so many tents we've got to
keep
doubling down on those solutions and
that sense of urgency
thank you next question please
next we go to a line of coco mcavoy with
fox 11.
hey coco how are you
hi thanks for taking my question um my
question is also about schools of course
experts have come out saying there are
mental health concerns with kids out of
school
and there are some schools in la private
and catholic that
are reopening with waivers so um you
know what makes lausd different
and will you end up intervening with the
union to get students back in school and
if so
when so i am available to help anybody
as you know i intervened when the union
uh went on strike and was very happy in
the same space i'm talking to you from
right now
to work together with superintendent
buettner the the board
and the union to find a good resolution
to that strike
i'm available but i think the most
important thing to remember is we don't
have to go very far and while it's good
to see other schools
figuring out a way to do this we've seen
this internationally in other parts of
the country
so it's not that nobody has done this
before as i said we point to our own
city experience of actually running
child care and education programs or
spaces for education programs
safely over this last year so i'm
convinced we can do it and now with
vaccines in place especially if those
are prioritized and i agree
with the board i agree with
superintendent buettner that has to be
the highest priority or one of the
highest priorities
of groups along with our seniors you
know folks that are especially
vulnerable in our health care workers
let's get that done one of the most
difficult things about this is not
knowing
what the vaccine supply is going to be
but you can feather in
our teachers you can feather in our
school workers and get that stood up
even
one grade at a time and i hope that we
will all feel that sense of urgency for
our children
you're absolutely right whether it's
mental health costs whether it's
in i think our lowest income communities
as i shared last briefing that old
saying somebody drops out of high school
in third grade so those young children
especially who these are foundational
years and if we miss them
they may miss their opportunity any
follow-up coco
okay thank you i'll take the next
question
next we go to the line of ron min with
los angeles time
hey ron go ahead hey mr mayor thanks so
much for taking our questions um
there was a statewide poll recently that
offered a kind of a confusing sense of
where voters um
uh thought about to stay at home orders
uh
53 said that they the orders they found
them
ineffective but then 57 said that they
were
science-based and uh 59 said they were
necessary
so i i just kind of wanted to ask i mean
do you think um
i mean you've defended the orders as as
working
um uh do you think you know you and
other officials are
uh you know expressly explaining
um you know your your view on how the
orders uh
have been um effective and why do you
think that
uh there's so much division over or not
over whether or not these orders um
have been affected thanks so much
absolutely ron thank you and a great
question
i have no doubt uh that our swift action
saved lives
i mean just look at new york a similarly
dense metropolitan area
they were further into the progression
of the disease and waited a week later
and even with the horrible january and
december we've had i think per capita
death there are still
quite north of double per capita from
that
surge that a matter of days
was the difference um so i know
thousands and thousands of lives were
saved
why do people have mixed opinions about
it and i think in my opinion it's
because messaging has been very unclear
we had a federal messaging that was very
different than that and planted seeds of
doubt
sometimes things change too quickly or
suddenly
both opening and closing and i think
that it was especially at that national
level
the way this became more partisan rather
than
based in the science so it did not
surprise me at all to see those numbers
but if you're asking my personal opinion
i have no doubt
i know that that there were lives
thousands of lives saved by our swift
action
and if i had to do it all over again i
would in a split second
thanks ron follow up
yeah another subject um
next week is the 50th anniversary of the
sulmar earthquake
you know one of the most consequential
earthquakes um in
l.a history can you talk a little about
you know would you be able to reflect a
bit on that
milestone and and what do you think uh
we should be doing
you know you know as we go forward in
terms of earthquake safety issues thanks
so much
absolutely and thank you for your your
strong uh um
coverage of that and inspiration for a
lot of the work that we've done here
um yeah i was born a week before that
earthquake so i'm i guess i just let the
cat out of the bag i'm turning 50
tomorrow
my mom used to joke you were born and
that was seemed to be the big news for
me and then suddenly the earthquake hit
we were living in the valley obviously i
was too young to remember it
but just like the northridge earthquake
i think there were 65 lives
lost in silmarquake it really was
something that fundamentally
changed our attitude towards
saving lives and dealing with
earthquakes we changed our building
codes as a result of that so that we
wouldn't see
you know the hospital that kind of
pancaked because of the building type
and crushed
people on an entire floor that was
changed to protect lives
just as after northridge we changed
things and
i'm very proud under my administration
for the first time we didn't wait for a
bad earthquake to come before we looked
at soft story buildings
and some of the non-ductile reinforced
buildings here
um i think that that was probably the
beginning of
of us awakening to a moment that we had
to leave that we lived in earthquake
country it had been
a number of decades since los angeles
had faced a
big earthquake um then it came kind of
steady every 20 years or so
because we haven't had one in that time
period we are especially vulnerable
and just to reiterate that point it's
why i wanted to be proactive i prayed
and i still pray that not only during my
time mayor we won't see an earthquake i
hope we never do but you can't as a
mayor pray an earthquake won't come you
have to assume it will
and that's why i took difficult action
even though an earthquake
hadn't visited us to do those upfront
costs figure out a way to try to
share those costs with our between our
tenants and our landlords
and i think we'll look back and see this
moment that again
lives we can't quantify but thousands of
people are alive because of swift action
what comes next i think is as we've
talked about you know
our taller buildings um our you know
skyscrapers and others and looking at
the work that we have to do
to make sure to me it's not just our
laws but do we have a plan
um i hope folks as they've been at home
this year recognize how important is to
have that plan
to stock up those basic necessities and
to get to know your neighbors
and as soon as we can once again be
together take advantage of the city's
program called rylan which is
ready your la network and it basically
allows you to have a meeting with all
your neighbors we bring in the
specialists
and you learn who on your block has that
disability or that pet
who's a senior so we can care for one
another and during this pandemic we've
learned a lot about caring for one
another i hope those lessons carry over
to our preparedness for earthquakes too
thanks mr mayor appreciate it
next question please
next we go to line of isaiah rocha with
la weekly
please go ahead hey isaiah how are you
how are you thank you um the new cal
state la vaccination site will obviously
increase the city's daily capability to
vaccinate
uh does that mean that a significantly a
significant amount of vaccine doses will
be coming with it
and will it be enough to meet demand um
we will not have enough uh um supply to
meet demand for months i mean i think
the demand
is most people you know well north of 50
would take it tomorrow if they could so
the short answer that of course not but
anything that comes with more supply
is positive and i'm the more the merrier
they were very clear that this is not
going to come at the expense of doses
for existing sites that still have more
capacity
be they the county mega sites dodger
stadium or other places
and so i would hope that this is we were
looking at what comes next after dodgers
stadium we have a couple sites
in mind if this helps be the next step
and we don't have to staff that and it
comes with
ready willing and able federal and state
workers that's great news
um so as long as we're not poaching each
other's uh supply
and they were very clear we're not going
to be this is going to be added supply
added locations hopefully added
convenience and the only thing i'll be
spending a lot of time with our state
and federal partners is making sure you
can set up a location
in a community surrounded by high impact
but you have to make sure you're getting
to those people in that community
because people will drive from far away
people are more economically empowered
people at less risk
can take those vaccines because they
kind of are savvier at finding that out
we want to make sure through the
programs we're doing like the mobile
um the mobile initiative i mentioned
tonight
uh by getting text messages out to
people who live
in the most vulnerable communities that
people know
that it's good public health it saves
more lives and it's the right and
equitable thing to do from racial
justice to
uh standing our economy back up to get
to those communities that are just hit
so i'm excited about that location we're
gonna
help make sure it's a success and that
it does come with additional supply
thanks jose next question please
next we go to the line of victor cordero
with estrella tv canals
and then you can answer in english and
then in spanish i'm going to try to be
brief
and please do not kill the messenger i'm
just outside with the field and i talk
to our people
and business owners and this is what
they say number one seems like we have a
lot of plans
to get everyone vaccinated and to
provide funds for the needed
but the fact is that not it's not enough
for everybody suffering from the
pandemic so
tell us what we can do number two you
spoke about helping the homeless
community
paying hotel rooms and creating shelters
which is a very noble cause
but what do you tell those who are
working very hard
every day and they don't see the light
at the top what can we do
gas prices rent is unreachable
buying a house forget about it and
number three really quick some people
are helping their family from abroad
to get vaccinated in our county
is there a protocol to punish both the
visitor
and the healthy hand thank you
absolutely my pleasure so
i'll go backwards in english and then
forward in spanish
so in terms of the protocol uh yes i do
believe the county is looking at ways to
make sure
the policy is if you work in l.a county
healthcare workers for instance
that you're eligible otherwise you have
to be a resident of la county
um i'm sure you will be able to find
cases where folks sneak in but
overwhelmingly i know when we had an
article for instance that a few people
who didn't qualify had gotten vaccines
yeah that was like
a fraction of a fraction of a percent so
you know we're batting 99.99
uh percent of folks that are here um we
appreciate if people do know
of anybody trying to um take a vaccine
essentially from minelli county
stakeholder whether that's a resident or
a worker
we want to make sure that those are
there but the county i know is focused
on that
second in terms of what do we say to
everybody who's
suffering that's exactly why from the
beginning of this i have focused
all my energies into advocating for
public dollars
and raising private dollars to help
those who are the most vulnerable and
that does it's not an either or
we can't help the homeless or help
people who are housed but vulnerable
we have to do both because we don't want
those people becoming homeless
and we don't want to keep homeless
people on the streets
so whether it's utility assistance the
biggest program in the country
through our department of water and
power and through our federal dollars or
the largest rental assistance program
that goes into
landlords pockets and helps our tenants
be able to pay their rent
or the angelino card which made sure
that immigrants weren't bypassed
very proud of that work that we've done
and the continuing advocacy
to raise more money and to make sure
that our federal government
passes that legislation in that
legislation will be tremendous help for
every day
hard-working americans just on the edge
and in terms of the business owners and
the supply they're right
we simply don't have enough vaccine and
we won't for a long time
i talked to a senior said i'm 68 why am
i having such difficulty getting an
appointment
said there's 1.5 million seniors in la
county and there's 160 000 doses a week
so just for seniors that would be 100
weeks now
that's just for the first shot imagine
for two shots so we
know we need more vaccine but we also
know more vaccine now
is starting to come an increase this
week thanks to the biden administration
of sixteen percent hopefully we'll see
that double over and double over because
we need seventy five thousand vaccines a
day
not a hundred and sixty thousand a week
in espanol por los
duenos
in
[Music]
[Music]
with that i'm going to turn to spanish
for my address tonight as well thank you
everybody who's tuned in
be safe and we'll see you soon
we want to start
hospitalization
[Music]
diagonal
[Music]
a
good evening
[Music]
foreign